[Applause]
the moment australia's new prime
minister acknowledges his victory
leading the labour party to power for
the first time since 2010. i'm honored
to be given the opportunity to serve as
the 31st prime minister of australia
an mp for 25 years anthony albanese is
one of australia's longest serving
politicians who came from a humble
background and campaigned on a platform
of unity and optimism
it says a lot about our great country
that the son of a single mom who is a
disability pensioner
who grew up in public housing down the
road in camperdown
can stand before you tonight as
australia's prime minister
i have put forward
a positive clear plan for a better
future for our country
and i have shared the two principles
that will drive a government that i lead
no one left behind
because we should always look after the
disadvantaged and the vulnerable
but also no one held back
a phone call from incumbent scott
morrison to the labour leader conceded
his party had lost power after nine
years
thank you so much for standing
by us at this time and i know you will
continue to do that into the future to
my colleagues tonight
who have had to deal with very difficult
news and have lost their seats tonight i
as leader take responsibility for the
wins and the losses that is the burden
and that is the responsibility of
leadership and as a result i will be
handing over the leadership at the next
party room meeting
just who will replace morrison's liberal
leader remains to be seen his deputy and
treasurer of the country josh feidenberg
lost his seat to an independent
it was always going to be a tight race
outgoing prime minister scott morrison
marginally behind in the polls in the
lead up to the election
unlike in 2019 the polls run true this
time round
climate change was the driving election
issue the morrison government was not
thought to be doing enough in the global
fight as bushfires and floods devastated
australia's backyard
his response to both tainted his public
popularity
while labour hold the majority they have
not yet secured the 76 seats needed to
win the election outright which could
lead to a hung parliament
making the increase in votes for
independence so crucial they've been
dubbed the teals a rising group of
mainly women in the moderate middle who
have campaigned on climate change and
have changed the balance of power their
support will mean everything
no matter the final count this election
signals a new climate down under
madeleine ratcliffe sky news